it's friday and that means it's time for
is the view reveals just how tone deaf
it is and a classic kids show gets
serious but first shameless pandering by
the left of the social justice warriors
joining us with all the details he's
back
raymond arroyo all right raymond get a
two for tonight double trouble with you
tonight
it never stops though what are the 2020
candidates doing now
laura it's almost embarrassing at this
point cnn as you referenced earlier did
another 2020 town hall marathon which
and this could tell us how 2020 might go
it tanked their ratings the equality
town hall
gave the dem candidates an opportunity
to curry favor
with their reliable lgbt constituency
let's start with cory booker who was
literally throwing himself at one of the
questioners
that is one of the most handsome
haircuts
were you about to say the same thing i
was gonna
all right you are a beautiful man
all right many people have no idea make
our president bald again
yes i'm here for it all right
how adorable uh so what are we saying we
sing some
make uh maba hats how to make america
bald again is this how they're gonna
win michigan raymond yeah well they'll
only
they'll only have visors so you don't
want to ruin the natural dome laura
you know beautiful heads joe biden
naturally was right in the center of
this
now he's been known to shall we say
embellished stories a bit laura
so i wonder just how much of this story
is true
this is about he and his father
encountering a gay couple watch
two well-dressed men kissed one another
as i was opened the door
and i hadn't seen that before i looked
at my dad and he just looked at me said
it's simple honey
they love each other when i came out and
i came when i publicly stated well
that would be news i got something to
tell you
i kind of figured it out a while ago
i wonder what cornpop would say laura so
i don't even know that was just sad for
all
no it was i mean it's it's a desperate
attempt to pander and aside from mayor
pete
all of these candidates are at a loss
because they're not gay or lesbian so it
becomes a pander fest
but you're talking about 82 percent of
uh of
lgbt people vote democracy so it's an
important base
yeah right kamala harris really takes
the cake though here with her entrance
watch
my pronouns are she her and hers she her
mine too is this what we're going to
have to do
when we won't go into a room like is
that what was that the new
hello before you look great how are you
doing okay
and what's your personal pronoun so he
had to apologize cuomo did he said
please read when senator harris said her
pronouns were
she her and hers i said mine too i
should not have
i oh my god lord he had to apologize for
that
it wasn't funny but still it was his
attempt
as pathetic as it was this was all it
was really
a pander fest for hours and hours it
didn't help the ratings
joy behar was serenaded by people during
her birthday on the view
and well watch
[Music]
the time has come
inquire indict
impeachment
okay
[Music]
i mean what how flat can one sing
first of all i'm focusing on how flat
the tone is
must we make a christmas carol this
profane by tilting a birthday
celebration and a christmas carol toward
impeachment it's ideology all the way
here it's sad
oh oh well well i just hope we uh
i just hope we can actually have a
christmas season without bringing
impeachment removal i mean a partridge
in a pear tree all under the same
conversation
don't count on it my dear see you next
unbelievable you have a great weekend
coming